the blocks to our manifesting power are
real deep they live in the underbelly of
our soul because remember we manifest
what we believe not necessarily what we
talk about or think about that can help
that starts to change your energy change
your point of Attraction that's a thing
that works but what we truly manifest
what we genuinely manifest in life is
what we believe on a guttural level and
so the true practice of manifesting is
to release the beliefs that hold you
back from stepping into the truth of who
you are here to be and the way that we
change the core belief systems that keep
us stuck in the patterns that block our
manifesting power is by tending to the
younger parts of us that believe that we
are unworthy unlovable inadequate not
safe that we have to do everything that
we have to be in control that we're not
good enough we're not seen hey it's EV
Carmichael and I make these videos
because I need them because I want to
wake up every single day and get pushed
by somebody who's doing a lot more than
me and in watching their videos it
inspires me to be bolder to have more
courage and go chase down the life of my
dreams and I hope it does the same for
you so today let's learn how to
reprogram our minds and manifest things
into our lives
enjoy rule number two is reprogram your
mind with Bruce Lipton 95% of our
behavior is coming from sub below
Consciousness and we're the ones that
can't see it when we play it but
everybody else of course is uh seeing
exactly what we're doing so the whole
idea is are you living the life you want
or are you living the life you've been
programmed and the answer unfortunately
is most of us are living a life we've
been programmed and and the programming
comes from other people so it's not our
lives the reason let's give a reason why
programming occurs okay uh the brain is
a computer most powerful computer that
human have ever experienced but it has
parallels to computers and number one is
this um in the old days when you would
buy a computer before they put the
programs in you could bring it home
brand new computer plug it in push start
boots up screens on and I say do
something and people well no I can't do
anything you got a brand new computer no
first you have to put programs into a
computer before you can use that
computer the brain of a of a human is
the same thing uh the screen lights up
in the last trimester pregnancy it's
ready but there are no programs so the
first seven years of a child's life is
the brain is not operating at the higher
level of Consciousness higher level
higher vibration that's what we talk
about we put wires on a person's head
Electro and seil graph read brain
function a child up through seven is not
operating at Consciousness except for a
little bit it's primarily operating at a
lower vibration called Theta and I said
well what is Theta I say it's expressed
as imag ation so that's how uh children
can have a tea party and they pour
nothing into the cup and then they drink
the nothing and then they explain how
that was the best tea they ever had or a
child rides a broom saying it's a horse
in the child's mind that is not a broom
it's a it's a horse but it's mixing
imagination and reality but Theta is
hypnosis and the significance of that is
children have to learn how to become a
member of a family the rules member of a
community the rules I go
how how can an infant a young kid learn
these rules they can't go to school they
can't read the book and all that and I
say you don't have to Nature provided
Theta hypnosis so that they can observe
the parents the family and the community
just observe their behavior and download
those as programs age seven then that's
when they start to become more conscious
and engaging themselves first s years is
programming but after age 7 95% of your
life is coming from that that program so
if you can program the child for the
first seven years and the rest of the
life of that child is actually an
expression of that program hi I'm Bruce
lion author of the best-selling books
the biology belief spontaneous Evolution
and the honeymoon effect I'm here to
thank Evan carmichel for featuring me on
his YouTube channel and I want to let
you know that Evan is giving away links
where you can watch the First episodes
of my special Gaia series entitled inner
Revolution for free Evan is making this
offer to thank you for watching this
video you will find the links in the
description section below thank you rule
number three is visualize with Jen cetto
do you think we have to go through an
identity shift in order to see money
differently and to be able to receive it
differently I think you do absolutely
that's a really great way to go at it so
what was your you know the key words
around your identity with money when you
didn't have much versus the key words
that you would speak about with yourself
or what money is once you started to
unlock more money well it wasn't
necessarily around identity my words cuz
I did have two very serious mantras um
but there was a lot of visualizing
myself with money and like I I wrote
about buying the Audi and you are a bad
and like I'm not the kind of person who
drives an Audi are you kidding me like
and like almost feeling like this the
guy who like test Dr with me be like get
out of here I know who you are you can't
afford this exactly so um
so but my mantras is really like and
before I started make money I said I
can't afford it to pretty much anything
you could throw at me my first words out
of my mouth where I can't afford it we
are buying into an identity as somebody
who can't afford stuff we are also
proving it you know what you speak you
want to prove because you want to be
right and it is sort of the foundation
of your reality so when I say I can't
afford it a 100 times a day I'm
subconsciously pulling in proof like
look at the car I'm driving I'm living
in an
like I make this much money a year I'm
I'm building all the foundational blocks
to prove that I can't afford it and that
becomes my reality and then that becomes
my I like to call it familiarity Zone
because Comfort zones are not
comfortable interesting right so so then
I'm just proving it over and over and
over and that becomes my reality rule
number four is visualize your goals with
Dean graziosi when you think of your
goals that is the number one thing
everybody talks about instead of setting
a goal looking
forward right let's pretend it is one
year from today and we're back here
celebrating and it was the best year of
your life that's the framework in which
I would love for you guys to look
through setting your goals instead of
looking forward through a busy life Look
Backwards at the best year of your life
and what had to happen when I say Look
Backwards and pretend it's the best year
of your life what your brain will
automatically go is oh yeah I want to be
making more money I want some more fre
freom oh I want to lose that 10 lbs oh I
want to get the intimacy back in my
relationship that still I want to be
really I know it sounds like I'm
splitting hairs you're still looking
forward of what you wish could
happen I've trained my brain over the
last two decades that when I do this
exercise and and we don't have to do it
right here when you do this exercise
it's not about looking what you hope to
happen it's about saying it already
happened and how do you feel looking
backwards meaning put yourself in that
spot and if it's visualization if it's a
little quiet time if it's reflecting if
it's why you take a walk if it's in your
shower when you're meditating whatever
it is picture it like I literally C I
literally can spend time thinking about
where I'm going to be in a year from now
and I can literally get goosebumps and I
can feel it as if it exists right now
you know people talk about manifesting
and all it is manifesting you got to do
the work it's not about just dreaming it
and hope it happens I'm not a believer
in that a lot of people say you set the
intention the universe will deliver
you have to set it up and you
actually have to do the work you can't
just say oh I'd like to have a million
dollars in my bank account let me go
back to my old habits of surfing on the
internet and watching Netflix and hope
that million dollar shows up no we got
to we got to do the work so we'll get a
little deeper but the first thing is is
we must have that compelling future of
our own designed and for me I literally
can put myself in this place and I
remember writing down okay this is what
Mastermind has to look like and I
remember writing down 100 miles and oh
we're going to do a big launch and we're
going to call it the knowledge business
blueprint and I remember writing it down
and I was writing down as if it already
happened I literally if you can see the
hair on my arms is standing up right
here because I can visualize because
I've been practic this for so long that
I visualize it and I see
it that is a great practice then once we
see it then the part that I think has to
happen as soon as I was done visualizing
I didn't go
done I dreamed it up no then I got my
ass to work like who do I need to learn
from to do this who do I have to model
what patterns of successful people
who've already done this that I could
model and do in teaching this and then I
started making the list of what I had to
get done so that fantasy could become a
reality this might sound like this is
what everybody does but do we we all
agreed if we eat better and work out
more we'd be in better shape but most of
us want to be in better shape but we
don't eat better and we don't work out
more so a lot of us want to be next
level successful and we're looking for
something else magically to come along
and it's not going to we have to
visualize what it is we want to be and
if it was the best year of Our Lives we
have to get as detailed as possible
remember fuzzy targets don't get hit
don't just say I want to be a coach
making a million dollars a year what
does that mean what kind of Coach how
many coaching sessions how many clients
do you need listen if you said I want to
be a coach and I want to make a million
dollars a year and you were sitting with
me and I was Consulting for you I'd
reverse engineer it how many people how
much do you make per person right if you
say I can make you know uh it's $10,000
a year per person okay so that means you
need 100 clients okay you need 100
clients over 12 months it's going to
take you first month you might only get
five so if you get five the first month
and then the second month is seven then
the third month is is 20 how many do you
need to get I would lay out all right
first month 5 Second month 12 third
month I need 22 and I'd have a freaking
goal every month on how I could get
there and nothing would stop me I would
go back to what I teach you guys I'd
know my why I'd have my compelling
future I already visualized it I knew
how I feel once I made a million dollars
being a coach I know how I would
visualize how the people I'm coaching's
lives would change I would think about
if I'm saving marriages or helping
people eat better or learn how to sell
or learn how to go vegan or or a million
other things I would think about the
lives I'm changing and I would literally
craft the plan saying okay a million
dollars as a coach okay I need a 100
clients that's an average of 10ish 8ish
a month right whatever that is I might
not get as many of the first ones so I
got to stack up the other months and
then I'd say okay what is my plan to get
the first five in January and I would
craft the plan to get my five $10,000
coaching sessions in January and that
would be my whole Obsession and if I got
four well I got to get an extra one in
February if I got six I'm like I'm ahead
of the game Let's bust it in February
and let's keep this little cushion that
I have rule number five is shift your
Paradigm with Bob Proctor I had been
raised to believe that if you're going
to earn a lot of money you've got to be
really smart I knew I wasn't that smart
but I was earning a lot of money so I
knew that wasn't right
um
I was raised to believe if you don't go
to school you'll never get a good job I
didn't have a good job I owned the whole
company I couldn't figure it out do you
know it took me N9 and 1/2 years well 9
and A2 years later I met this man that I
showed you his name Leland Val Vandal he
um he changed my life completely he
introduced me to a concept I'm going to
introduce you to and when he did that it
was like everything i' had been studying
I've been studying a lot of information
but I'd study this book I'd give this
book to people and they didn't change
and what he did he brought everything
together for me in a relatively short
period of time now here's a couple of
things he told me if you'll go back
screen scunt and he said Bob he he he
pointed out he said you are a unique
individual and he said so am I so is
everybody else and he said you can
literally create your own economy you
can do that and he said the only thing
standing between you and what you want
is yourself he all about the Mind Bob he
say it's about your marvelous mind then
he started thanks God then he started to
talk to me about the mind and he said
you know it's a strange thing Bob when
we get talking about the Mind nobody's
ever seen the mind they have never seen
the mind now keep in mind that I was a
very uneducated person um when you talk
about the mind I mean I would think of
psychiatrist psychologist behavioral
scientists no he said you want to get
rid of those ideas he said the way I'm
going to explain it to you was the way
it was explained to me and he said um we
can change we can show children how the
mind
functions and he said I'm going to show
you something here that's rather
interesting and he said Bob
understanding the mind and uh and
working in harmony with the laws
governing the mind is essential if you
really want to win in life and then he
started telling me uh what a paradigm
was and he said a paradigm is a mental
program that has almost exclusive
control over our habitual behavior and
he started talk about that he said it's
a program in your subconscious mind that
controls your behavior and the Paradigm
has almost exclusive control over our
habitual behavior and almost all of our
behavior is
Habitual now said I want you to think
about this and I want you to think about
it we get out of bed in the morning and
uh we bang away we go we move into a
routine and if you're living with
someone else you don't mess around with
their routine because you just don't do
that we've all got a routine and we go
into a routine and we do that day after
day and most people do it for their
whole life ear nil us used to say most
people tip toes through life hoping they
make it safely to death it's rather an
interesting concept and the Paradigm is
the program in your subconscious mind
now I said here's the crazy part about
it Bob the people that write this
program the ones that wrote the code for
the program um they really didn't know
what they were doing think of this for a
moment I've got a computer here it's in
a phone I've got another computer right
in front of me and then here I've got um
I've got a pad and um these are
computers now there's people write
programs for these computers they write
code and they really know what they're
doing and they're very very good and the
program for me to put the slides up here
that's a program it's a PowerPoint
program and um these things work like
like a charm well the people that are
writing the code for them are very well
educated and really understand what
they're doing but he said the people
that are writing the program for the
code that runs your life they didn't
know what they were doing now most
people don't even know that they have a
program think of this for a moment how
do you account for a person going to the
very best schools in the world getting
prestigious degrees then spend the rest
of their life losing how do you account
for that how do you account for the fact
that a person will come up with degrees
that'll run right off the end of a
business card and maybe not able to get
a half decent
job very insecure how do you account for
that well I'm going to tell you how
there's a part of your mind that gathers
information there's a part of your mind
when you read the book you store the
information in that part of your mind
but that part of your mind is not the
part that controls the behavior of this
thing that you're living in your body is
an instrument of your mind it is an
instrument of your mind and it's your
body that moves into action and produces
the results you're getting and rule
number six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is prime your brain
with John aser so I have my goals I've
got them laminated
and I've got him for health wealth
relationships career business and I've
got them laminated usually in my car
I've got them in my briefcase I've got
them in my office I've got them in my
home and I cognitively prime my brain
every day I give my brain instruction
this is what I want you to focus on this
is the beliefs that I want you to have
these are the habits required to achieve
this goal
and I get emotionally charged with that
vision and that goal and then let it go
if I've plugged in tuned in paid
attention with the right intention then
I don't have to have any tension
whatsoever to that and if I've created
my plan of what needs to be done if you
come to my home gym you're going to see
the goal you going see a picture of the
body that I want you're going to see
what the focus is for the month you're
going to see the Strategic plan of what
I'm doing every day you're going to see
my uh my measurement of where I'm at in
relationship to the goal and you're
going to see one thing that says the
promise or it says
why in that year when I was really broke
and I was really broken I was working at
La Unified School
District I was miserable I was miserable
because I wasn't living in my dream I
was just doing a Jil a o and then one
day I said what what do I need to do I I
need to I need to buy my
freedom that's what I need to do I need
to buy my freedom oh I don't know about
buying my freedom I don't know about
buying I don't know about having money
saved up my family didn't have money
saved up my mother used to tell me oh
this money is burned in my pocket so I
know two things about money it's hot and
we can't keep it long we'd always have
one week where we had all the food in
the refrigerator and then one week where
we were the refrigerator was empty right
come on come on some of you guys know
about that to this day I spend so much
money on groceries you guys oh my God
it's like I'm feeding like a family of
10 cuz I'm so afraid of anybody ever
being at my house and being
hungry and so I I wrote a check to
myself galani was
three
$110 I took it to the bank well was
Fargo I started a new
account the next check I wrote
$125 and just like the first check I put
in the memo line funding my dream I
wasn't even clear what the dream was but
I knew there was something in my belly
who who in this room know you got
something in your belly there something
here I'm not even clear about it I don't
know how clear you are but I wasn't
clear about it but I knew there was a
calling on on my life greater than
working for La UniFi school district and
no disrespect to La Unified School
District it just wasn't my
destiny I wrote another check in two
weeks
$146 funding my dream now I started
melling the checks in because I didn't
want to see my
balance cuz I don't want to go
shopping cuz I you going to repeat what
you learned right until you decide to
not repeat what you learned so I mailed
the check in and I wrote another check
and I wrote another check and every
check I wrote I made sure it was 5% more
than the first check the ne the previous
check I sold my Tima I had a car note
sold my Tima bought a clunker cuz it
didn't have a car note now I can write a
bigger check fun in my dream I moved out
of my three-bedroom three B three bath
house and moved in became a roommate
with my friend who smoked I put towels
at the base of the door so the smoke
wouldn't come through the door I was
willing to be inconen vegan are you yes
I'm just saying I'm just I'm just
showing you the story I just the charge
I just gave you I stopped getting my
hair done that was when I started going
natural I I stopped going out I I
stopped going out dancing I stopped
going out to dinners my family didn't
know what was going on they thought oh
my God you know it's La she's on drugs
but she's not losing weight so maybe not
I don't know what's going
on I kept writing bigger checks to
myself
$900
$900 I mailed to W Fargo funding my
dream
$1,100 melted it to W Fargo funding my
dream I still wasn't clear what the
dream
was I just knew I had one and it was
being born through me and I needed to
give it a
chance that's all I knew you don't have
to see 2,000 feet in front of you just
see
200 and run to the
200 yes yes yes yes you don't have to
see it all three and a half years later
i' written a check to myself every two
weeks for three and A2
years I didn't go out for three and A2
years I didn't go dancing I get didn't
get my hair done I didn't get my nails
done for 3 and 1/2 years are you willing
to be in convenience for your
conviction I walk in to Wells Fargo 3
and 1/2 years later and I said hi God
bless you hi my name is Lisa Nichols she
oh my God you're the fun in my dream
lady I was like yeah I guess I am and
all of a sudden all the tellers came
running around the manager came they're
like oh my God okay oh my God we have
been wondering we all got the same
question y'all know what the question is
right what's your
dream I was like
um I'm not sure but I know that it
includes inspiring
people having people believe in
themselves
again teaching them how to get back up
when they've been knocked
down having them to be willing to give
thems a thousand Second Chances and
every time they get to 9.99 press
reset I'm not sure what it's going to
look like but it's just going to help
people I said I came to check my balance
I've been writing a few checks to you
guys I said yes you've been writing a
lot I said I just wanted to check my
balance said you don't know your balance
I said no I got this really big stack of
summary bank statements at home cuz my
mama said money Burns her pocket and I
don't want it to burn my pocket I want
it to pay for my
freedom I said I just came to see what
my balance was if I had enough to fund
my dream as a gets clear she wrote it
down everyone's excited she wrote it
down turned it around to me I looked at
it I said oh no my name is Lisa shant
Nichols and my social security number I
said that is not my money and I am not
taking that money CU you're probably
going to want it back so just fix that
error right
now and they looked at me they said you
really don't think that's yours I said
no my family's never had $5,000 in the
bank or $10,000 in the
bank that's
$62,500
in the
bank they said Miss Nicholls and
everyone teared up the manager teared up
the tellers teared up they said Miss
Nicholls whatever your dream
is I think you can fund it now I looked
at my son gilani who now was five or six
and I said jilani
our lives are going to be a little
different now baby galani said
yeah Mommy can we can we now go to
McDonald's see for three years I've been
telling Jani I'll make you a Big Mac
Mama makes Big Macs better than
McDonald's and so it began with $110
check so I don't know what yours is I
don't know what your radical look like
for some of you your radical was coming
here right yes yes and this is the
beginning yes yes this is the beginning
of your radical this is the this is the
be the next best step this is the first
step and so I just stop by to let you
know you're on the right path and and as
you ramp up as you ramp up you're going
to have questions you're going to be
afraid I do more things afraid now than
I do Fearless
cuz the bigger you play the bigger your
breakdowns every single one of my errors
in the last five years have cost me six
figures like every single one every
single one of my errors has required me
to call an
attorney like they're just big cuz I'm
playing
big I'm playing big so be willing to go
to the
edge and this is where you are
here be
willing to go to the
edge and not just lean
over and feel the
breeze and watch the people
jump and watch them sore and look
through the windows at all the people
who are living great lives don't just go
to the edge and feel it be willing to
lean feel your heartbeat feel it that
lets you know you're alive that lets you
know you're okay fear fuels you fear
lets you know go get more information
fear let you know stay up a little later
and study fear let you know get up a
little earlier fear let you know ask for
help fear is informing you it's not
stopping you it's just another emotion
like love and compassion and gratitude
we just made it paralyze
us see fear doesn't stop me fear informs
me and when you get intimately connected
with the fear I feel it and I'm moving
forward anyway I feel it and I'm going
to love anyway I feel it and I'm going
to invest in me anyway I feel it and I'm
going to show up and play anyway when
you get connected with fear it becomes
your best friend and when you stand on
the
edge you feel the
breeze you feel the
fear and you leap anyway the biggest
message I want to get across when it
comes to the law of attraction is that
it requires effort it requires some type
of action that's why in the word
attraction you see action in the word
you don't just get to write down
something on a piece of paper or have a
vision board or you know map something
out or cut out photos and and look at it
in front of you every single day or
write down things on a piece of paper
and think hard about it for a few
minutes and then expect everything in
your life to change and to be this
magnet of opportunities have everyone
that you want in your life attracted to
you money good health opportunities with
your career that's not going to happen
overnight like that and I wish it did
but it's not that easy so there are some
beliefs and actions that we need to take
place in order for it to work and that's
what we're going to do by diving into
today so the first thing you want to
think about is switching from negativity
to positivity so many people get caught
up in focusing on what they don't want
to happen in their future and I want to
talk about this a little bit towards the
end of this video on how to focus on
some of the negative things that could
happen but really focusing on the
positive for the main part of your life
we'll talk about that towards the end
because this is an important distinction
but they start living almost in constant
fear of what could go wrong and what
won't work out and when we come from
this place of well I don't know if I put
myself out there you know it's not going
to work out and then I'm going to get
made fun of and then people I'm going to
be embarrassed and I'm going to be
stressed and no one's going to love me
and then we go in this rabbit hole and
this kind of cycle of fear and anxiety
and that is not how you attract good
things in your life you can't start from
your way of being of negativity and fear
and expect to attract beautiful things
in your life so we we need to eliminate
the negative selft talk and an
environment that's easy to get stuck in
sometimes can be the negative self talk
and there's so much negativity in the
world world and if you don't actively
work to shift your focus to shift your
thoughts and your mind that negativity
will consume you and that's where the
Law of Attraction comes in now for me
it's about focusing Less on what I don't
want to happen in the future and
actually focus on what I do want and
again I think a lot of people focus on
what they don't want too much and you
start to attract the things you're
thinking about I don't want this I don't
want that those things start to come to
you you start to see them
it's like the ex old example if someone
says you know don't think of a pink
elephant you start to see it and you
start to imagine it if you say well I
don't want to be poor you start to feel
it and you start to imagine it and you
start to have anxiety around it so you
want to really think about the positive
things in your life you want to think
about what do I want to attract who do I
want to become what do I want to
overcome so for example if you're
becoming a negative person you're more
likely to attract more negative people
rather than positive ones because
positive people won't don't want to be
around you you know negativity keeps
company and so does positivity when you
start to see other positive people that
are like you you say I want to hang out
with those people those people are going
to continue to lift me up I can lift
them up it's a good cycle but the
negative stuff you start to attract when
you talk about gossip and you talk about
bad news and you talk about comparison
and judgment and anxiety and stress that
feeds in a community of other people
that speak in the same language so you
want to shift your language and start
thinking more positively and if you feel
like you aren't deserving of a loving
relationship a loving partner you're
most likely going to attract the wrong
type of people in your life and if
you're focusing on how much money you
don't have in your life right now or how
your business could fail you're not
going to be able to focus your energy on
the right clients or the products that
will take your business to the next
level or the skills you need to develop
to help you grow now your thoughts
dictate your actions and where your
energy goes so you want to be thinking
about what can I do to replace these
negative thoughts the anxiousness or the
fear how can I replace it so my energy
can go any more positive direction and
again where you put your energy into is
what you attract so if you're thinking
negative thoughts all day long you'll
probably to attract that if you're
thinking gratitude and positive thoughts
you'll start to see that show up
differently so how can we put the Law of
Attraction into practice now let's go
back to our examples and apply a new way
of thinking if you are caught in
thinking negatively about the world and
about yourself this is so important what
would change inside of you if you looked
around and you wrote down five things
that you're grateful for about the world
now this for me is part of the secret to
the Law of Attraction it's the
foundation is gratitude it's your way of
being must be grateful in order to
attract new things there's so many
things in my life that I should not have
attracted
because I didn't have the skills because
I didn't have the tools because I didn't
have the education because I didn't have
the money because I didn't have the
resources so many things that I
shouldn't have attracted but because I
had the foundation of
gratitude passion Joy curiosity those
things started to come to me and they
can come to you as well if you come from
that place of gratitude as your
foundation so you want to think about
what are these things that are important
to me in my life you know it can be
simple things it could be like this cup
of coffee that I have right now it can
be that I have a roof over my head that
I've got quality friends that I'm
healthy you know that I'm walking in
nature today it doesn't have to be some
grandiose thing that's happened to you
to be grateful for I'm so grateful for
these little present moments with people
that I care about to spend an hour on
the beach to go for a walk with a friend
to have a good conversation with someone
and talk about something that I'm going
through for me that's just as meaningful
the moments in between the big moments
are just as meaningful so write down
these things or think about these things
this is something I embed in my daily
life when I wake up I think about what
I'm grateful for when I go to sleep I I
think about and reflect on the things
I'm grateful for from that day and it's
just my way of being for as much as I
can now I'm not perfect I make mistakes
and there's times I'm negative but it's
something that I try to really focus on
as much as possible so instead of saying
that you're not enough that you don't
deserve success what if you looked in
the mirror on a daily basis I dare you
to look in the mirror on a daily basis
and say I am enough and I do deserve the
results that I want to create in my life
because I show up because I'm consistent
because I work hard because I care about
my work if you looked in the mirror and
you did this consistently for 30 days
and you actually used the word action in
attraction and you put it into practice
on a daily basis towards that growth I'd
be amazed to see what you attract and
what you manifest in your life or if you
felt like you weren't deserving of a
loving partner and just kept focusing on
the wrong people what if you said you
know what I am deserving of a loving
partner because I care deeply about
those around me and I'm worthy of
feeling deeply cared about myself and
what if you started to change your
thoughts and behaviors around yourself
and say I'm not going to keep doing the
things that I've always done I'm going
to start showing up differently and love
myself not needing someone else to love
me who maybe isn't in the right mindset
and start distancing yourself from those
typical patterns that you've had in the
past and love yourself first and see
what you attract from that loving
grateful place with yourself or if you
are in a tough Financial spot maybe
you're struggling financially and you've
been trying to start a business or a
side hustle I've been there I know what
this feels like it's not fun for a long
time I was living on my sister's couch
and I didn't have much money it was
really stressful I remember remember
this feeling of being stuck feeling like
I was never going to make any money and
when I was focusing on that feeling of
I'm never going to make this money I
feel stuck I feel trapped when's this
going to happen feeling this anxiousness
this stress around it it was really
impossible for me to think of creative
ideas it was impossible for me to take
action because I was living in the
stress as opposed to the gratitude for
what I was having in that moment I
should have been focusing on you know
what my sister is a lot me to stay here
for free so I have some time to learn a
new skill I made $100 this day I should
be grateful for that not a focusing on
what I'm lacking or what I don't have
but what I am creating on a daily basis
and I started to ask different questions
around this time like how can I be of
service to other people how can I add as
much value to someone else or what are
my top skill sets that I can use to my
advantage that no one else has like what
do I have I started writing a list of
all these different skills that I had
even when I Dr didn't think I had many
skills I still wrote down a list of the
qualities I have of the skills from the
past that maybe I could apply to right
now and when I began asking those types
of questions I started attracting the
people who needed my skill sets and
services and I finally started to make
more money than ever before because I
was thinking about serving others I was
thinking from a positive grateful
standpoint about helping others and
starting a side hustle which turned into
a business instead of thinking negative
about not having any money or I'm
sleeping on my sister's couch and why is
it taking me so long to create this and
I'll never make anything from this
situation I started focusing on how can
I add value as much value as possible to
this one person in front of me right now
how can I serve them how can I create
for them how can I connect someone to
them that could help them what can I do
to add value and help someone else
achieve their goals because I think as
Zig Ziggler said if you want to
accomplish all of your goals help other
people accomplish their goals and that's
what I started focusing on not what I'm
lacking but how can I give and how can I
add value to other people when you focus
outward on service you start to really
attract some incredible things in your
life it's unbelievable the ripple effect
the domino effect one person helping
another person how it comes back around
to you when you have a goal in your head
it's not even a goal it's a fantasy it's
a dream when you have a book like this
you can call it your goal book and you
write out your goals and you go through
I'm just about to take you through bit
by bit stage by stage you go back to
that but you can look at it you can
touch it you can just make it real so
remember if you do not write out your
goals as a plan and write out how to
accomplish them you don't have a goal
you have a wish you have a dream you
have a Daydream if you want to go get a
pen get a nice little book like this you
can do it on your phone too you can make
make a document in your
computer and be prepared to make your
goals real so let's start now get your
book pause this if you need to go and
find one create one and I want you to
pick a goal and do not even start with I
want to lose £5 I want more money these
are what I call wishy washy goals no if
you can make your goals really you might
as well make them huge big enormous
phenomenal so if you say well I want
more money that's my go oh hang on a
minute hey I got $10 here there you go
you go well that's not my goal but you
said I want more money and I learned
this when I used to work with women who
were infertile that come in they go you
know I just want to be pregnant I want
to be pregnant so bad if I was just
pregnant I go well as I look at your
notes you've been pregnant six times I
know I keep
miscarrying so being pregnant is not
your goal is it what
isn't your goal to carry to fullterm a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great mom yeah
that's my goal why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal is to have a perfect baby
how about this my goal is to get lots of
attention for what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants explosive gas so
let's start with a big goal pause if you
need
to take some time open your book and
write out a big goal now you can have a
career goal on whatever I'm going to
have my own company create my own
business invent something you can have a
relationship goal my relationship is
wonderful we grow in loving and
respecting each other and you can have a
health goal but I want you to pick one
only one one not three not five not 10
one goal it can be career can be Health
can be love pick one goal and then I
want you to decide why you want that
goal so much so the first thing is I
have a goal I want to have my own
business that's my goal and now you're
going to go to the next page and write
out why do you want to have your own
business so much and the more reasoned
you can write out why the more likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many whys as you
can and remember you can come back any
time to this and think Oh I thought of
another why and another why so leave
plenty of space take your time and when
you've done your wise go to another page
and write out who will benefit from you
achieving that goal of course you will
but who who will benefit for instance if
you have your your own business you will
employ people who will benefit maybe
your kids will go to private school
maybe your business will allow you to
help your partner have their business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal the more reasons
you have to achieve that goal so write
out who will benefit from you achieving
go who how and why will they benefit
you're going to buy your Mama house put
your niece and nephew through private
school did you think of your mind as
like the genie in the bottle that says
your wish is my
command and I want you to understand
that every thought you think and every
word you say is a blueprint that your
mind body and psyche must make real so
when you write out your goals don't say
I wish I could be rich I long to be in a
loving relationship write it as if it's
already happening I am a millionaire I
am in a loving relation you might go
that doesn't make sense it does make
sense because your mind only works in
the present tense when you say next year
I'll have a bikini body it doesn't know
what next year is and so you must write
your goals in the present tense I am I
always I have I do this new page is
about your
discipline how many hours a day you
going to spend working on your
goal how often are you going to come
back to this book and look at it I want
you to write out I am I always I have I
do and I want you to fill that in you
see the best goal in the world will not
work if you don't work and many people
fail at this point they write at a goal
my goal is to be a millionaire my goal
is to be be famous my goal is to be
wildly in love and they think that's it
it's not it if you want to be madly in
love write at all the reasons why but
then you have got to put yourself in
front of the kind of person you want to
share your life with if you want to
start your own business and you have a
reason why you also need to have the
discipline to meet people who will fund
you sponsor you joint venture with you
so I want you to really understand that
the best goal will not work if you don't
work you can have the start point but
you have to keep going many of the most
successful people ever say well you know
I had a goal Luther vandros had a goal
to be a
rockar and people said well you're an
overnight success he would I don't think
so you know I sang Jingles for KFC for
12 years that's a long night 12 years
and people said but Luther you're
singing on television that's cool get
paid a lot of money for KFC said yeah
but it's not my goal and he stuck it out
and many people have got so close to
success and had to keep going and you
have to keep going
so look at your discipline and decide
you will give more to your goal give
even more work on it look at it write it
out think about it talk about it you
must be prepared to give so much to your
goal in fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
so learning to create our minds the way
we want is the basis of creating the
world the way we want there is a
wonderful story in the yogic
lore on a certain day a man took a walk
he went for a long
walk accidentally unawares he walked
into Paradise fortunate isn't
he he just took a walk and he landed up
in
Paradise after this long walk he felt
little
tired so he thought oh I'm tired I wish
I could rest
somewhere he looked around there there
was a nice
tree underneath which there was very
cushiony
grass so it was inviting he went and put
his head down there and
slept after a few hours he woke
[Music]
up well rested and he thought oh I'm
well rested but I'm feeling hungry I
wish I had something to
[Music]
eat and he thought about all the nice
things that he ever wanted to eat in his
life and instantly all those things
appeared in front of him you need to
understand they the services like
[Music]
that and hungry people don't ask
questions food came and he
ate stomach became full then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to
[Music]
drink all the nice things that he ever
wanted to
drink he thought about it and all of
them just appeared in front of him
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he
drank now with a little bit of alcohol
in him you know Charles Darwin told you
all of you are monkeys your tail fell
away not me Charles darn told you that
you were all monkeys and your tail fell
away and then you became human yes
definitely the tail fell away but the
monkey in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished
mind as markata which means a
monkey why we are refering to the Mind
as a monkey is
[Music]
what are the qualities of a monkey one
thing about a monkey is it's unnecessary
M and another thing about the monkey is
if I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean
imitation monkey and imitation have
become
synonymous so these two essential
qualities of a monkey are very much the
qualities of an unestablished mind
unnecessary
moment you don't have to learn it from
the monkey you can teach it to the
monkey and imitation is full-time job of
the
mind so when these two qualities are on
a mind is referred to as a
monkey so this monkey became active
within
him he just looked around thought what
the hell is happening here I asked for
food food
came I asked for drink drink
came there must be ghosts around
here and ghosts
came oh the ghosts have come they're
going to surround me and torture me he
thought immediately the ghost surrounded
him and started torturing
him then he started screaming in pain
and said oh they're going to kill me and
he
died just now he said he he's a
fortunate
being the problem is he was sitting
under a Culp of RKA or a wishing
tree he asked for food food came he
asked for drink drink came he asked for
ghost ghost came he asked for torture
torture came he asked for death death
happened now don't go looking for these
kalpa rukas in the forest you can barely
find a
tree these
days a well established mind a mind
which is in a state of Sam yukti is
referred to as a Culp of
fiction if you organize your mind to a
certain level of organization it in turn
organizes the whole system your body
your emotion your energies everything
get organized in the direction once all
these four dimensions of you your
physical body your mind your emotion and
the fundamental life energies are
organized in One Direction once you like
this anything that you wish happens
without even lifting a little finger
actually it would help to assist it with
activity but even without doing any
activity you can still manifest what you
want if you organize these four
dimensions in One Direction and keep it
unwavering in that direction for a
certain period of time right now the
problem with your mind is every moment
it is changing its direction it is like
you want to travel somewhere and every
two steps if you keep changing your
direction the question of you reaching
the destination is very remote unless it
happens by
chance so organizing our minds and in
turn organizing the whole system and
these four basic dimensions of who you
are right now in One Direction if you do
this you are a kalpa yourself anything
that you wish will
happen but right now if you look at your
lives everything that you have wished
for till now if it happens you have
finished everything and everybody that
you have desired for if all of that
lands up in your house today could you
live with
that once we're empowered like this it's
very important that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly
directed if it is not so we become
destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the
planet so what should have been a boon
we are making a curse out of
it what has brought incredible levels of
comfort and convenience to us in the
last 100 years or so has also become a
threat to our life simply because we are
not conscious action we are in a
compulsive state of
action so organizing our minds
fundamentally means moving from a
compulsive state of activity to a
conscious state of
activity you might have heard of people
for whom they asked for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
true for them generally this happens to
people who are in
faith now let's say you want to build a
house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying I don't want it so on one
level you're creating a desire that you
want something on another level you're
saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not
happen someone who has some faith in a
God or in a temple or or whatever who
have simple minded Faith Works only for
those people who are simple-minded
thinking people people who are too much
thinking for them it never works a
childlike person who has a simple faith
in his God or his Temple or whatever he
goes to the temple and says Shiva I want
a house I don't know how you must make
it for
me now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
this simple Act of
Faith now he believes sha will do it for
him and it will
happen so is Shiva going to come and
build your house no I want you to
understand God will not lift his little
finger for you what you refer to as God
is the source of
creation as a Creator he's done a
phenomenal job there's no question about
it could you think of a better creation
than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well but if you want life to
happen the way you want it because right
now the very Crux of your happiness and
your well-being is this if at all if
you're
unhappy the only and only reason why
you're unhappy is life is not happening
the way you think it should happen
that's all it is so if life is not
happening the way you think it is it
should happen you're unhappy if life
happens the way you think it should
happen you are happy it's as simple as
that so if life has to happen the way
you think it should happen first of all
how you think with how much Focus you
think how
much stability is there in your thought
and how much reverberance is there in
the thought process
will determine whether your thought will
become a reality or is it just an empty
thought
or how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process this possible is
something possible or not possible is
destroying
Humanity what is possible and not
possible is not your business it's
Nature's business your business is just
to strive for what you want
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hasht believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see
seven manifestation experts talk about
attracting success check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there what about your mind all day when
it's complaining and it's yelling to
people and it doesn't like stuff what if
you're attracting that way so you
eventually catch on that it is not about
getting what you want it is about
learning to find out that what you
really want